foreign
ER there's no end of these good
I kept thinking you know will people get
tired of them I just don't know no
they're just increasing in popularity
yeah well well there's a subject in the
universe that no one grows tired of oh
not okay the search for life that's up
there but you know what I think is even
higher than that oh black holes oh God
yes people love them some black holes
yeah and you know gen 11 has been our
go-to on this but she comes to it as a
physicist yes so she can speak of black
holes sort of in the abstract in the in
the in the general relativity of them
and the blues music that they play the
black hole Blues exactly but when a
black hole shows up just
in the house you know in the
astrophysicist house I gotta bring in an
astrophysicist black hole expert so let
me introduce you to my friend and
colleague sabik Ford that savic welcome
welcome to Star Talk
hey Neil and Chuck very lovely to be
here excellent for me excellent and so
you uh you were in the City University
system of New York which campus is that
I am at borough of Manhattan Community
College okay BMCC
yeah yeah
and the grad Center so the graduation I
get around that's the CUNY grad Center
c-u-n-y graduate Graduate Center
excellent and so your last I checked
your research interests are what black
holes are doing in the Galaxy you know
as they eat stars as stars orbit them as
they Collide so you're you're a black
hole Maven in the house this day in
black hole I am proud to claim that
title for the record black holes don't
suck they're awesome oh okay okay all
right I got you right I thought you're
gonna go where uh what is it there's no
such thing as gravity Earth sucks
it's where I keep all my stuff I can't
complain too yeah so tell me which check
recent
about a black hole that's just isolated
with a whole trail of stars
freshly born behind it like just
discovered like days ago so cyber who
who made this discovery
uh the team was led by Peter van dakum
at Yale could you just tell me what that
news story was and what the hell is
going on in our backyard
so it is very cool and it's not
super in our backyard it's actually
about uh
eight billion light years away oh wow
okay so
it's a day's trip yeah
yeah but Mike might want to pack a
suitcase you could be gone for a while
uh but it's it's
um one of these super massive black
holes so I am very interested in we
think that most Galaxies have super
massive black holes in their centers we
know that ours has a supermassive black
hole it's about four million times the
mass of our sun in the center of our
galaxy and that's like kind of a small
one
I gotta tell you I do right now yeah
even even the Andromeda galaxy the
nearest big Galaxy test what's its mass
what's the mass of its black hole it's a
little closer to like 10 million times
the rest of our sun so yeah yeah I know
let me tell you that's that's
embarrassing in the locker room
breakfast right there the same right
across the way right okay yeah so this
one did we get a mass on this one yeah
so this is actually kind of in the
Andromeda territory maybe a little bit
bigger like two um or 20 million uh
times the mass of our sun okay and so
there's and and we think that there's
actually the the story that we've got is
that there might be three black holes
involved in this whole situation so yeah
three distinct black holes that have not
yet merged but we're just observing them
because we can't really observe them
because there's no light yes yes okay
okay yes and so like basically right
black holes give off no light and so so
how do we observe them and we have to
rely on them influencing matter around
them and if that matter can give off
light then we can observe the influence
of the black hole
from what it did to the light exactly
okay yes yes yeah and that's generally
like how we how we do these things so
um this is like another example of it
but it's a very weird example it was
totally unexpected the people who were
who found it were not looking for it
they were looking at something else in
the frame and then they got this weird
line like straight line which is not
something you don't see a lot of
straight lines in the universe so they
saw this really long straight line and
just to be clear yeah this is evidence
that we can discover things we're not
looking for okay because yeah people
wonder that right is it are you are you
do you have receptors for things you
didn't ask a question about yet the
answer is yes we do yeah sometimes
science is like looking for your keys
you know it's like you you lost your
keys you go looking for them you're like
look at that twenty dollars
look at that how great is that yep yep
so like that was totally what happened
here they were not looking for it they
were looking for other stuff and they're
like whoa 20 bucks that's pretty great
guys we've got this line and lines are
weird so you know anybody who's looking
at a picture of galaxies in space and
they see like a straight line across it
it's like hmm and that's a big thing
right you don't have necessarily Eureka
moments you have hmm that's weird
moments and so that's what happened here
these scientists were looking for
something else entirely and they saw
this straight line and it was really
long and really thin so it's um about 40
kiloparsecs in length which is about the
width of our entire Milky Way galaxy oh
okay great and so it's really about a
hundred thousand light years yeah okay
yeah it's really long and
um and it's pointing back at this other
Galaxy that's a lot smaller than ours
which you know is it's been you know
it's 8 billion years old so we've
Galaxies have grown in that time they
were smaller it's pretty normal Galaxy
for the time that it was in but it's uh
small for modern galaxies and they were
trying to figure out what could cause a
straight line we see sometimes we see
jets that shoot out of supermassive
black holes that live in the centers of
galaxies and they make straight lines
but this one they looked at it in a lot
of different uh wavelengths and they
were trying to figure out well if it was
a jet it should be spreading out as it
goes away from the center of the Galaxy
and they didn't see that kind of
behavior they also didn't see any
evidence that it was an active Galaxy
which was swallowing matter so if black
holes are going to shoot stuff out
that's usually while they're swallowing
material and there's no evidence of that
so they're like what could this straight
line thing be it actually gets narrower
the further away from the Galaxy you go
and they realized when they were looking
at it that if it was a jet it should be
giving off radio waves and x-rays and
it's not doing those things but it looks
like there's a lot of really bright
young Stars wait so these are those
other wavelengths you said that they
looked in and they didn't notice because
if you just look at one wavelength you
you what what do you know you don't know
anything right until you see exactly
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can it's like if
you had like black and white photography
right you can't always tell what's going
on but if you have like a color
photograph things really pop and you can
learn a lot from that so they basically
went out and got a lot of X-rays and
radio wave data and
um besides that visible light and they
could tell that there were stars that
are young really young and they they
realize that if a supermassive black
hole had been shot out of the nucleus of
the Galaxy about 40 million years ago
then it could as it's passing through
the gas that surrounds that Galaxy in
every Galaxy it could cause little
condensations of that gas that would
collapse and form new stars and would do
that like in a straight line because
it's being shot out in a straight line
and so as it's going along it's going to
have this leave this trail of star
formation behind it so so a gas cloud
mining its own business might not make
stars so it has to be perturbed in some
way such as the black hole passing
through it punch punching through I
guess yeah it's kind of like if you've
seen like those cool videos of like a
bullet shooting through a gas right and
it leaves that little turbulent wake
behind it where it's got all of those
like funds and so that that those
turbulent chunks could then collapse and
form new stars okay so I'm fine with
this but somewhere in there you said it
got shot out of a galaxy yeah yeah yeah
right like it's got shot out of a galaxy
so can we go back to that right now
please it's 10 million times the mass of
the Sun it got shot out of a galaxy you
don't just you know that doesn't just
like happen right so this is why you
need three black goals for this to
happen so the basic idea is that when
you have two galaxies that Collide
they've each got a supermassive black
hole in the middle then the two black
holes come together and they can form a
binary supermassive black hole where
they're orbiting around each other and
they orbit really really fast
if you were to have a third Galaxy come
in and drop its supermassive black hole
in then you could get some kind of
interaction like a gravitational
slingshot and the binary could kick that
third object out and this thing is
actually if this interpretation of this
finding is correct this thing is going
at 1600 kilometers a second so savik how
fast is that it would get you from the
Earth to the Moon in just a matter of
minutes
well took the astronauts three days so
just for comparison yes we're talking
fast
all right so so this is the first of its
kind that we've known yes yes this is
definitely the the the first clear-cut
example and it's also very exciting
because the binary black hole that
should have been what was responsible
for shooting out this one that's going
on this straight line that they have
observed we we won't necessarily see the
binary but it is in the right Mass range
that in the future we could detect it
with gravitational waves and so if they
Collide if they collide with each other
no not if they collide with each other
so just for existing just as a binary
because there's a space mission that's
going to launch in 2034 Lisa the laser
interferometric gravitational uh array
and it is built to detect binaries of
like 10 million times the mass of the
Sun so I got it okay in gravitational
ligo was detecting black holes that are
tens of times the mass of this yes so
the million times that's a whole other
regime detection regime yeah you need a
totally different telescope but totally
different everything so but and if you
were to be much more than 10 million
times the mass of the Sun you'd actually
be too massive for Lisa to see it and so
you would need even a different tactic
so this is really exciting that like we
could point to this one and be like we
think there might be a binary right
there so not everything in the universe
feeds us in the wavelengths of our
telescopes of of our of our chosen
telescope you gotta yeah you got to meet
the Universe on its own grounds in a
sense yep yeah
so so now part of me is thinking savic
part of me this is just the antagonistic
part of me is yeah well
they don't know what this thing is
so
let's say three black holes made it it
sounds it's like why not just say aliens
did it I mean what how how
frequent is a three black hole thing are
you is this really a thing as you
frequent as frequent as black holes come
home from college
they come home from college that binary
which is the parents are like Trevor
listen your mother and I have decided
that you need to pay rent and we're
gonna have we're gonna need to get 900 a
month from you and Trevor is like for
900 I could get my own place and the
parents are like exactly get them out
get out Trevor wait wait Chuck there's a
very sensitive generation listening to
you now about this this very same issue
you're absolutely right after that yeah
yeah so seven don't worry kids I'm not a
homeowner either
wait so savic so at what point do you
reach for Extraordinary explanations
so
there is I would say this is not that
extraordinary in the sense that a lot of
people have suspected that there will be
these systems of three black holes and
one getting ejected and all you required
was three Galaxies for that which we
know surely has happened yeah definitely
like we've got examples like I can point
to you for like there's great Hubble
images of like triple Galaxy collisions
like they happen all the time so Chuck
both of you in my lifetime because
Savage a little older than you uh I I
was around when that cottage industry
was born within modern astrophysics just
the study of merging galaxies and it was
called mergers and Acquisitions
it was in the 80s it was very 80s Wall
Street mergers and action galaxies are
good
yeah
the more they eat the better right
that's good so so all right so that I'm
glad to hear that because you know
they're going to be people saying aliens
did it right they have some Black Hole
uh uh some black hole Cannon or
something right yeah yeah there might be
there might be a guy we all know at some
particular institution who might want to
claim that and the rest of us will laugh
and say
all right well Sonic thanks for this
yeah and and and just I'm delighted that
you you could bring this expertise to
our explainer occasionally our
explainers do current events and I like
reaching out to my peeps out there well
again savik thank you for that bit of
expertise dropped into our our weekly
explainer thank you for having me lovely
and Chuck always good to have you there
man always a pleasure Neil deGrasse
Tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
thank you